let's think about how or what 1/2 times
5 represents so one way to think about
it is that this could be five one halfs
added together so you could view this as
1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2
which is the same thing as 1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 plus 1 over 2 which is equal to
5 halves which is equal to 5 halves the
other way to think about this is that
you start with 5 things you start with 5
things you start with 5 things so let's
say that's one thing let me copy and
paste that so they all look the same so
and then let me paste it so that's two
things
that's three things that's four things
and that's five things so the other way
to think about it is you start with five
things and you take half of them so what
would be half of this well let's see you
have five things so you would mate you
would get five divided by 2 would be two
and a half but so you would get you
would get this far let me make it like
this so you would get this one you would
get this one and you would get this one
now is this the same thing as five
halves
well what happens if we divide each of
these wholes in two halves so let's do
that so if we just multiplied so we just
divide each of these into two so we have
instead of having five holes
we now have ten halfs we now have 10
asks how many of those halves have we
filled in well we have filled in one two
three four five so this is also equal to
this is also equal to five halves now if
you're looking for how we could write
now so far we just did it thinking about
what multiplication actually means but
if you said well you know how did I how
did I compute this well the way you
could think about it and multiplying
fractions is
actually straight forward from from that
point of view is as long as you can
express both of them as fractions and
five we already know is the same thing
as five ones so this we can just
multiply times 5 over 1 5 over 1
so now that I've expressed both of them
as fractions I can just multiply the
numerator so 1 times 5 1 times 5 over
over 2 times 1 over 2 times 1 and what's
that going to be equal to well 1 times 5
is 5 2 times 1 is 2 2 times 1 is 2 so
once again we get 5 halves